how do you see the chances your anchor
of mine is winning game two and
finishing of the match um somehow i
don't think that he's gonna
actually play aggressively for the win
here i think that he's satisfied with
actually securing a draw because that
then that puts duda in a must-win
situation and that's very very difficult
so there we see magnus opening with his
kingsporn and
i'm very excited now because this is the
kara khan and this is my favorite
opening on the planet i play on a
regular basis and i look forward to
seeing how magnus treats the position as
white and also how duda handles magnus's
ideas
yeah and it's really interesting this is
kind of a mirror of the game that ended
magnus carlsen's
125 game unbeaten streak because in that
in that match up magnus carlson played
the carrick on against duda and uh this
time its roles reversed dude using that
weapon ivanka's favorite opening against
the world champion and there's lots of
tension in the position ivanka what do
you think of this line it's it's a very
solid line so i mean the whole idea is
that you do allow black to capture the
pawn in the center and you do allow this
trade of queens but then white is saying
you know i've got a little bit of extra
space in the middle of the board so it's
quite uh an interesting it's trendy
so maybe duda who is not a regular
karakan player
might not know exactly how to treat this
position yeah and i must admit i've
played some kind of informal blitz games
with magnus and he used this one against
me quite a lot when he had white any
time i played the caracan he would use
this setup to try and neutralize me uh
so clearly magnus likes these positions
as you mentioned there ivanka trading a
set of pawns in the center for black
would have just ended in a queen trade
and because of the match situation that
was only going to help magnus if the
queens disappear he's not going to lose
this game uh he's just too good in those
end games magnus
so dude instead of releasing the tension
trading pawns in the center as we
mentioned he's just pushed upon himself
and that's to create a fianchetto uh
option uh possibility for his bishop the
black bishop coming out to a long
diagnosis soon meanwhile magnus okay
trading a set of pawns in the center
this is really uncommon
yeah i mean i was going to ask you look
shocked i am totally shocked because it
really doesn't fit in with what i know
about this position i was expecting the
white knight maybe to come and develop
itself to the d2 square
that's just losing time
and uh
interesting did he did he do this to you
and uh wow dude coming up with surprised
on every move but dude are coming up
with something quite creative he's
offering a trade of dark squared bishops
and that's not common either for this
type of variation normally black's
bishop has a really nice home uh on the
g7 square as we mentioned the fianchetto
on a long diagonal now this exchange of
dark squared bishops it's not clear who
that's going to favor also if white now
with his dark square bishop goes and
captures this black bishop that's just
moved black will end up with a knight on
the edge of the board and that has pros
cons
it's a really weird opening and you did
mention that you have a white lost time
that's because white moved his deeper in
one square and two minutes later moved
it again
so not recommended for anyone at home
not recommended at any level actually
unless you're the world champion and you
can get away with things but uh yeah
very very surprising normally white's
main move by far is to actually step
forward with the other pawn in the
center of the board earlier once black
prepares the fiance so uh yeah magnus
now the computer likes his position says
plus one but
slightly over enthusiastic it feels like
because this is still relatively
standard just with a weird move order to
reach this position and uh okay
meanwhile magnus doesn't go for the
bishop trade on black's terms he says
yes you can take the bishops off but you
have to spend the time doing that and
instead developing his light squad
bishop creating a pin yeah it's a very
natural and yeah the evaluation bar
seeing that actually it's pretty
balanced neither side with any big
weaknesses so far
yeah i mean i'd have seen this uh dark
square bishop foray to the edge of the
board and offer itself up for a trade
but i haven't seen it when the bishop is
sat there on the c1 square so i like
magnus's choice you know just developing
the light square bishop and putting the
question to black are you going to trade
off bishops in order to complete
developments what are you going to do
with your light squared bishop and now
this is going to be the most pressing
issue for black because take a look at
magnus's little luxury move there on the
right pushing harry one square
it's a very subtle move but what it does
do is it deprives the white the light
squared bishop of the g4 square and this
means that suddenly it becomes a very
awkward piece this light square bishop
for black because it doesn't have a nice
square to go to
yeah mine is just laughing he's always
laughing
but you know something i i learned
something when i did my chess talks
interview with henrik carlson is that
magnus plays really well when he's in a
good mood
and so magnus's team actually
prepare
they prepare jokes
which surprised me because i never i
just assumed it was like
spontaneous like chitchat but now they
prepare jokes they prepare conversations
as to things to put magnus in a good
mood and uh it was quite also really
interesting that they said that um
magnus last year became an uncle and uh
magnus's little nephew joined them in
the the world championship match and it
was he said it was really lovely to have
an infant that yeah because
this info you know brings such innocence
and enthusiasm so whenever it was a
difficult game for magnus you could just
play with this little kid his shoulders
would sink down and he could relax yeah
that's nice
all right well in this game it's a must
not loose situation for a young
christophe duda and if magnus wins it
it's over he will be the winner of the
charity cup
at this position though does it
you know often become winning for white
or black
it can do but that happens much later on
so
this type of opening it just
to me it shows that magnus wants to just
survive the opening not allow yankross
any activity um now if you look at
black's pieces half of them are still
asleep black's king's still in the
center and it's just hard to open up
lines as well no matter which pawn
pushes in the center black uh goes for
we'll just see some trades and that
definitely isn't what duda wants so okay
meanwhile dude attacking white's light
squared bishop a bit of a
committal decision but to me it says
okay it's a bit slow this pawn push
ignoring peace development magnus now
can trade off his bishop for a black
knight not what he likes to do remember
we talked about the bishop earlier
magnus preferring bishops over nights
usually but white gains a lot of time if
he does just capture this black knight
then white has another move to maybe
plant the white knight in the center of
the board bring white's rook opposite
the black king lots of tempting moves
here for magnus
and uh yeah either way it's still very
early days but
it looks like magnus has got a very safe
stable harmonious position and it is
becoming about maneuvering we mentioned
that favors the world champion at least
it did yesterday and uh duda just unable
to get this type of active chaotic kind
of imbalanced position where he really
thrives
so yeah it looks like decent strategy
decent choice in a situation where
magnus is happy with the draw would love
to get a win of course but uh not losing
is the key for magnus i think he's
chosen well in the opening dude
meanwhile you can tell in his body
language okay magnus choosing to keep
his bishops very characteristic of him
but you can tell him judas body language
he's not that excited by his position
he knows it's okay black is not losing
black's not in any trouble yet but it's
just not his type of his type of style
really
and look at that uda from studio oslo
our graphics operator
donated 16
thank you uda uda is also the one making
sure we have all these graphics up on
the screen so thank you for that as well
and
if this is the last game well then we
don't have a lot of time to uh make our
150 000
goal so if you as well have the
possibility to donate to unicef's
life-saving work in ukraine then please
do so and look at that stefan from the
us donated two hundred and five thousand
two hundred and five dollars thank you
so much i'm very
excited i see the bar going up our
donation bar
it's incredible you guys so thank you
for the chess community just coming
together in this crisis
and it's going to be exciting now to
follow that donation bar throughout the
rest of today however long it will be we
do have another move we do have another
move and duda not really dealing with
the problem of the black king the black
king is still stranded in the middle of
the board for now it's okay but dude i
just bring his rook across and magnus
solidifies the white pawn center if you
look at why it's porn in the center of
the board now really really firm it's
going to be hard for black to break
through that and this is actually what
we call the cult bad structure it arises
from lots of different types of openings
the queen's gambit the karakan and a few
others as well but it's all about
pattern recognition and magnus he's a
real connoisseur of that queen's gambit
of this type of pawn structure with both
colours this is where just having
studied games of previous world
champions having played all these
different types of openings himself will
come in handy uh duder may be slightly
less well-versed in this type of
structure
with especially with the pawns so okay
dude i mean what bringing the black
queen out still delaying his his uh
attempts to castle the black king and
it's getting risky for him it is kind of
risky i i have to say i don't really
like the way judah has handled this
position
uncertain
definitely because the more he delays
taking a decision with his dark square
bishop the more white has just improved
the position you know the rook is now
opposite the king
danger
and uh
i don't see what black the black queen
is doing and the black rook is doing
maybe it didn't even want to be there i
mean it's i think it's just way too soon
to take those type of decisions king
safety is what matters
and uh
yeah that's just uh yeah i don't know as
i'm a big caricom fan but uh i don't
think this is the way to play it yeah i
have i'm such a big fan of the caricom i
went and i've bought myself a caracon
jumper oh the chess 24 show that's cool
and i was uh standing outside
in the uh in my hotel during the show
and someone came and joined me he's like
cool jumper so i was like oh fellow
chess player
and then he kind of brought me down to
earth and he goes no
no but i have a i have a very similar
similar jumper says coco corolla and
then he kind of i was like okay
like the corona i was like yeah i get it
i get it but uh yeah it's a nice bright
red
it is ah the chess 24 store yeah i've
been i've been after one of the cups for
ages but i didn't get that so i thought
you know kara khan is my thing i've
written two books in it i
i like it yeah i love the opening so why
not just buy the hoodie definitely and
you guys you can also buy this fantastic
chessboard signed by world champion
magnus carlson current bid
5
100
that is amazing but
all money goes to an incredibly
important
case unicef's life-saving work in
ukraine
so i mean go ahead bid some more um 1
hour and 55
minutes left
in this auction
and we also have the air things device
also signed by magnus carlsen up for
grabs the current bid is 400
that one can also be yours it also
monitors air quality
in addition to having magnus's signature
and now young christophe duda is
thinking i'm wondering if his air
quality is a little bad today that first
game well that first game was it
was that one basically down to just
magnus playing some genius moves yeah i
mean it's hard to be too harsh on duda
even yesterday
he didn't play that badly duda but
magnus was just better and same in the
first game today magnus came armed with
a fantastic opening idea first of all
which duda just couldn't recover from
didn't know how to react to but even
later in the game when he was on the
back foot maybe dude are missing one or
two defensive resources but we can't
blame him because magnus was just too
powerful and uh sometimes in chess we
can get angry about our defeats normally
when i lose i'm angry if i played badly
or if i feel i kind of beat myself in a
way just kind of
made a blunder or something but duda how
can he be angry he's just coming up
against one of the best players in
history in top form yeah and
sometimes you just got to shrug your
shoulders and think okay
that happens that's life and uh okay
dude would like a chance in this game at
least and
uh he would like to feel that he played
one good game maybe at least in this
final but uh it's gonna be hard look at
the clock times already he's down four
minutes on the clock the black king's
still in the middle the darts were
bishops looking at each other
maybe we have to jump in to show why
he's thinking so long and why
two kairikan opening players here myself
and ivanka
are maybe biased towards white which
doesn't feel right
it's all because of this black king is
still stuck in the middle as evan
mentioned eyed up by the white rook
indirectly uh it's going to be feeling a
bit uncomfortable there but it is this
tension between the two bishops i
mentioned putting the bishop on the
square putting black's bishop
out here is quite creative it's
imaginative but the problem is
if you don't capture the white bishop
then what's it doing here it means that
the black knight is stuck defending it
at the top of the board if you do trade
however then the downside is after you
do finally develop your knight wanting
to castle your king of course then white
queen can get aggressive you've actually
helped white's queen improve herself
because look at this diagonal she
completely dominates the dark squares
now and she can actually jump into the
black position using the squares that
the black bishop has vacated and there
are so many weaknesses she's going to
sneak in attack this rook maybe
the black king cannot castle now you
cannot castle through check the white
queen covers the square next to the
black king and this only helps white so
dude trying to delay this decision he's
hoping that white is the one to capture
the bishops on black's terms and uh
actually he's just pushed his ball
forward but this loses a lot more time
and also
how is this bishop feeling about this
last porn move the bishop trapped behind
the white squared pawns and
yeah he's hoping magnus trades these
bishops because now the black knight
might actually uh sorry the black knight
might jump into the center it actually
finds active squares but magnus isn't
going to allow that exactly what he's
done magnus is going to continue
delaying that decision and in the
current position he just brings his
knight out black brings the knight out
too now that this diagonal is blocked
but magnus is going to start gravitating
his pieces maybe towards the king side
towards the right side of the board uh
okay he actually goes in the other
direction with this knight at least but
this tension opened up once more if you
trade as black then this white queen is
going to sneak into all the dark squares
you cannot trade that means you must
lose more time and i'm expecting dude to
just go back and admit he lost a move
with this uh with this whole maneuver he
came out but then he has to retreat now
back to this square you have to keep the
dark squares defended
and uh
one of the plans that is that white
often utilizes is actually to stick a
knight in the middle of the board
and i'm thinking could the white knights
jump there and then maybe even put
itself one square back and do some
zigzag motion just so it can get itself
over to the e5 square and then from once
a knight arrives on the e5 square it's
normally a launch pad for even more
attacks on the right side and it's not
just that ivanka i love your move
because you support the white bishop
coming out you defend the square with
the knight and you gain even more time
against the black queen we mentioned
duda maybe not familiar with this
openings or at least this setup because
he's put his bishop uh okay he retreated
it now but he put his bishop out on a
square then he had to step it back he
lost time he lost one move there uh he
put his queen on a square where she's
about to get hit maybe by the bishop
he's gonna have to lose more time with
her queen also this rook what's it doing
here yes it's a semi-open file but it's
staring at its own pieces he lost time
there and also he's put his bishop
behind his own pawns and that is not
good strategy in general so
magnus now he's got this really nice
option of dropping his knight back he
doesn't need to start with that maybe he
could bring his bishop out uh lots of
options you could even make an argument
for pushing pawns that's magnus very
type of
thematic move from him he always goes
for these types of pawn pushes it's just
really pleasant for white the evaluation
bar says plus 1.6
that feels slightly
kind of
slightly too much overestimating white's
chances but it's just that pleasant for
white black has no active ideas you
can't push pawns really on this side of
the board it's just too slow
and uh pushing in the center would only
get captured and okay magnus ins instead
using this square phrase bishop just
opening up the white rook on this line
and it's very one-sided traffic we're
about to see magnus maybe even launch
this pawn out the board going for the
black king
it just looks
like the worst possible version of this
opening for black
and uh let's go back to the players
because duda with the clock situation as
well still facing that uphill struggle
maybe he's just trying to surprise
magnus with all these weird piece
placements trying to get magnus out of
his kind of opening book especially
wanting to win now duder to uh equalize
today's score but
it feels like he's just been a bit too
creative and
as mentioned all of those small tiny
factors
they build up they add up into a solid
safe advantage for white yeah very safe
and
yeah we really don't like this position
and i love your suggestion of
stepping forward with harry and
beginning everything beginning the
attack and what is black going to do i
mean black's traditional plan in all
this is basically to hold the right side
of the board you want to be as defensive
as you want as you can over there and
once you've traded off a few of the
attackers then you kind of want to
concentrate on opening a line on the
left side of the board
but
you can't trade attackers this is the
big problem and instead black is just
sitting there with no space um black is
on the is in danger of getting
suffocated here yeah and look at this
dude has lost another move his rook
moved across to the square it previously
sat on that was a few moves ago and it's
moved again
i just think he doesn't know where the
pieces belong
and this shows maybe a lack of
experience in this type of pawn
structure but it also shows maybe
maybe he's nervous or just frustrated by
the fact that today has not gone well
for him yesterday did not go well for
him
so duda losing tempe with his bishop and
with his broken magnus trading off black
seemingly bad bishop but he's getting
the bishop yeah i was going to say what
do you think about this decision to
trade the bad bishop
um i kind of liked it actually because
like you say get the bishop pair and you
always have that idea of just softening
up the right side by pushing harry a
little bit and you can also maximize the
dark square bishop that's going to get
developed anytime soon um
yeah very very nice play by magnus and
magnus stepping forward with his queen
and in fact magnus doesn't even need to
play ambitiously either because this is
a solid position and a draw is also good
enough because it forces duda in a
must-win situation
and to me i'm looking at the cameras i'm
just thinking that duda
looks a little bit sad yeah and i had an
interesting chat this morning over at
breakfast with the swedish grandmaster
pontus carlson and we were discussing
emotions in chess and
we kind of agreed that
if you have if you feel angry during the
game because you've made a blunder
that is actually an emotion that could
potentially help you it could give you a
bit of fire but if you feel sadness
chances are it will never help you'll
just feel more and more despondent about
your position and you'll begin
just a crack
yeah you do begin to crack and it does
feel like that way for duda also
i mean he hasn't had to make any big
decisions he hasn't had to calculate a
single variation really in this whole
game so far up to move 17 but he has
spent 10 minutes on the clock under five
minutes and
the only questions he's had to answer
are where to put the black pieces and
he's done okay yes he lost a bit of time
in the process i was critical there but
it's just the clock times it shows how
sad he is how despondent how he's lost
faith i think duda he doesn't believe he
can beat magnus uh at least in this
match
and uh that's not a good sign as ivanka
mentions and white has a very clear-cut
plan firstly white is rock-solid it's
hard to break through for black or do
anything productive as black but white's
plan of marching the h pawn forward
towards the black king softening up
there i mean that is very one-sided and
just as i say it white does advance that
pawn forward this is just typical i mean
ivanka mentioned it i mentioned it this
is pattern recognition this idea happens
all the time for white uh in other
different openings as well meanwhile
duda struggling to come up with ideas as
black he has however played his rook
across one square moving his rook for
the fourth time this game already four
out of his first 18 moves were with this
black rook but uh he does have an idea
and uh now he wants to explode open the
center he wants to push the black e pawn
forward so finally duda stumbles across
a plan but it took him a long long time
magnus now has one question to answer
and that's what to do against this pawn
push uh if black had waited any longer
then white simply as mentioned you're
going to step forward with this pawn
maybe even say we give a move to black
gonna push this pawn forward and step
forward with the white king bring the
rook over and go for checkmate on this
line but uh at least duda is hinting at
doing something and it's quite thematic
as well it's quite typical if your
opponent plays on the wing you should
count it in the center so black now
preparing and magnus does play on the
wing he pushes this pawn forward i think
duda has to break out with the pawn in
the middle before it's too late either
now or on the next turn at least if you
push forward in the center you
you can try and exchange some pieces off
maybe exchange some knights maybe even
exchange a set of rooks later on and if
pieces disappear white's attack on this
side is going to be far less scary so
okay i at least like dude's plan now at
least his last move bringing the black
work across makes a lot of sense because
he's about to open up the position and
his pieces suddenly not that badly
placed and there we go the pawn does
push yeah
good decision by duda and it's nice to
see him
finally with an active plan and i'm
expecting after the night captures the
pawn i'm expecting magnus to finally
develop the dark squared bishop
the rogues do need to be connected and i
don't know okay i
didn't see that now there's an immediate
threat in the position after that
recapture because the bishop is
threatening to go to the h2 square give
a check and uh after the king moves rook
takes queen is a nasty nasty threat even
if the bishop is captured
black wins the white queen
discovered check and discovered attack
so this tension really annoying for
white two ways to deal with it
uh one is that you capture this bishop
in the center of the board but then
black's pieces might get active another
way would be to move your queen or block
this line with your bishop in the center
but uh okay duder despite the evaluation
bar not liking his decision he's getting
active he's trying to make a mess of the
uh of the position make a mess of things
and confuse magnus so big threat as you
haven't mentioned this bishop check
needs to be dealt with you have to block
the e-file move the queen or capture
this black bishop we know magnus likes
his bishop so i am slightly expecting
this one but then again it would come at
a downside that now white's queen is
attacked and this white pawn on the side
of the board also under fire
so yesterday you talked about we talked
about you know the bishops versus the
knights and you said judith polgar liked
her knights
caspar of lightest knights fisher liked
his bishops
has magnus had a clear preference
knights vs bishop are we now
starting to see yeah he is liking the
bishops yeah i think we always guessed
that he liked his bishops just from his
opening choices um you can actually tell
a lot of the time especially the way he
plays the sicilian
for example the way he plays
uh the one e4 e5 openings he likes his
bishops there he keeps them when he has
white he tries to take them when he has
black but this match especially nearly
every game we've seen so far magnus has
had the bishop pair and if you look
again white has two bishops black only
has one and we could even see a two
bishop versus two night scenario which
is actually quite rare just like we saw
yesterday if white goes and captures
this black bishop in the center of the
board with his knight right now
so it's it is weird how you see patterns
in
kind of in two days of matches which you
nearly never see in a whole lifetime
yeah but that's what's happening in
front of our eyes uh magnus just showing
us proving he does love those bishops
and uh as i mentioned there's one
downside to capturing black bishop in
the centre of the board now magnus just
trying to weigh up whether it's worth it
or whether to play it safe maybe moving
the white queen or or blocking up the
central line
and uh yeah magnus he's a bishop man i
prefer my trips too but knights are
tricky okay as mentioned one of the
options was to move the white queen i
didn't expect this square the white
queen going back to her start square but
she's at least out of the eye line of
the black brooks and duda he is getting
active look at those black rocks
stacking up doubling up on the open e
file
all right and thank you to uh yarco from
finland donating 23. we have made it
past 130 000 wow
that's incredible no i know i'm just uh
i'm so impressed and uh feeling so much
love for the chess community and all our
viewers around the world
for their incredible generosity brian
from the uk christian from norway thank
you to all of you but we have up to our
goal to 150 000 so uh please keep on
donating if you do have uh the
possibility to do that
and also the chessboard you guys
thousand one hundred dollars it's
amazing and uh but the auction it hasn't
closed so you can still make a bid for
it if uh you want to
all right yumanka you were going to say
something about the game
yeah i don't i don't believe you if you
don't
know what it was
no i think i always get i was probably
going to say i mean
i do like what judo is doing he has one
sneaky move he can still play the bishop
to the h2 give a check you know we like
checks but uh okay now magnus is time to
develop the dark squared bishop maybe or
maybe first capture the bishop in the
middle of the board i mean what are the
chances of duda even
thinking about winning it
yeah it's difficult isn't it it's still
difficult it's uh
almost
i would put his chances of a win at less
than 20 percent okay about you
i'd be slightly more generous but not
that much more generous to be honest uh
yeah i mean 20 percent
would make sense here it's roughly
balanced i mean he's been fighting back
dude actually the evaluation is slightly
in black labor
it's much better now than it was about
five moves ago for duda but that's just
because magnus is playing it safe i
don't think magnus has made any big
mistakes magnus could have been more
ambitious over the last few turns but
remember a draw suits him
so that's why magnus is taking these
safety first options and probably i
would say 50 chance this one's going to
be a draw and maybe 25 chance each for
either side but
yeah i mean it's it's still hard to
imagine white just simply has no
weaknesses if you look at most of
white's pawns yes white has a very far
advanced pawn that's defended that's
actually going to act as maybe a thorn
in black side on that king position but
apart from that white has no weaknesses
everything harmonious everything
defended it is that rather unique two
bishop versus two night scenario i think
i've only had that maybe
half a dozen times in my career and
we've seen it twice in two days now and
yeah magnus really loving those bishops
i expect him now to try and keep those
bishops if he can
at least he doesn't want all of the
minor pieces all of the bishops and
knights to come off because that would
be very balanced
but uh
yeah it's uh at least duda trying things
that's what we want that's what he needs
to do he's trying to imbalance things
and those black knights are slightly
more active than the white bishops maybe
for now for this next move or two yeah i
was going to say you know i was going to
actually eat my words and say i think
i'm going to take it back because
there's two nights like you say they're
a lot more active than i visualized and
also
there's a few
nasty tactical ideas in the air you know
move that black
white sorry would like to play was
actually to move the dark square bishop
out of the way you spotted it yeah you
know exactly what i was going to say you
would love to
yeah for example attack the rook take
control of the dark squares but this
kind of thing isn't really possible
because the knight will actually come to
the f3 square give itself away and
suddenly there will be questions asked
about the rook on e1 and it's just loose
and
so the dark square bishop can't move and
also
yeah that this is a very painful
position for white
and also there are other pieces that are
tied down for instance the white queen
she can't go off on a foray so maybe she
could try and step herself forward and
try to connect the two rooks well she
could do that but then maybe there are
there are ideas of the knight coming to
the g4 square and suddenly
if the knight on the other knight on d6
moves well we have a dangerous mating
ideas potentially yeah the queen and
knight uh we always talk actually about
queen and knights in general being the
ideal attacking combo the ideal
attacking duo but here there are even
two black knights attacking and uh if
they can combine with their queen that
would be very dangerous for magnus so i
wasn't wow okay i wasn't expecting a
queen move i wasn't expecting magnus's
move either this rook's seemingly active
but as jovanka pointed out it's a
tactical weakness it's a target for the
black knights magnus just pushed it back
where it came from
both sides losing so much time in this
game what do you think of that one
ivanka
it's surprising i mean but it's a really
radical solution to white's problems you
know he clearly wants to activate his
dark square bishop which is what i was
just gunning to do as well you know but
it wasn't viable to move that piece so
this is uh why he's played this rather
odd move the only thing that i don't
like about this is that magnus is
wasting time well
he's using too much time with his rook
putting his rook in the open line
putting it back again and uh
this is kind of a flag for duda to
actually step forward with one of his
knights this is the time now to play an
active move
and i fully expect him to jump with his
knight um
i can't figure out which one is the most
most attractive square it could be to
jump to the c4 square attacking a pawn
or even jump into the middle of the
board
yeah definitely looks like one of the
black knights should jump somewhere
right now magnus did slightly shake his
head uh the first time we've seen magnus
maybe a bit hesitant also his time
advantage has disappeared mostly
so yeah
magnus i don't know how he comes up with
some moves sometimes i said that in the
last game he came up with some crazy
imaginative attacking moves now he just
lost a move himself brought his rook
back where it came from first white
retreated the queen to the start square
now he moved his rook back to where it
stood about 10 moves ago
so both sides just coming up with some
crazy strange kind of bizarre waiting
moves but that's purely because they
want to avoid direct tricks direct
tactics that we pointed out on the last
go
so yeah one of the black knights is
likely to move dude they're just trying
to figure out he's spoiled he spoiled
for choice here he has a lot of options
but only two minutes to make this
decision yeah i i i i think he has to
jump forward with the knight and if i
were to make give it myself a kind of a
guess or force myself to make a choice i
think i would choose
to put my knight on the c4 square attack
the bishop attack the pawn
that looks very logical
due to hesitating he needs to speed up
he spent more than half his remaining
time on this one move
but it's not going to change the game
it's not going to
it's not a critical moment there's no
tricks there's no direct attacks there's
no captures threats
checks as we always talk about so he
needs to move it feels like he's frozen
maybe it's just the nerves and maybe
it's the lack of confidence after
suffering a few defeats against magnus
there's also been a change in the
position before he was just defending
and and you know he was looked like
he was going to suffer and be just
suffering for the long haul okay he
decides to centralize his night this is
this is good this is really good but he
could have taken that decision a bit
quicker
and i just worried about
that this change in momentum it means
that maybe he's gonna take a little bit
of time on the clock to shift and he
doesn't have that luxury he just has
over one minute and a half to make moves
and that's not a lot of time
especially with the critical moments
still ahead uh at some point things will
get a bit more lively uh it's still that
fight between bishops and knights white
doesn't want to go and capture one of
the black knights with the white light
squared bishop because the bishops once
they're separated they lose in power
white needs to keep both the bishops
alive ideally
because right now white's
kind of major pieces the queens and
rooks are inferior to blacks blacks
looks fantastic doubling up that's good
strategy in general black's queen is
quite flexible as you mentioned there's
some variations where she can actually
join an attack against the white king
along a dark square diagonal where
sometimes the black queen could slide
off to maybe attack white's pawns on the
left flank as well
but white needs to improve those pieces
so that's why i expect magnus to maybe
move his queen right now or maybe
i mean what can you do with the white
rooks that's a big question
uh i do think maybe magnus struggling
for moves as well i like dooda's
kind of last choice the more i look at
it that bishop retreat as well keeping
the bishops alive
preventing any trades black not being
able to capture either of them right now
but magnus's maneuvers have been very
very slow very time consuming he's
retreated his queen his rook and his
bishop now on the last few turns
not ideal for white
duda actually the momentum's on his side
on the board not on the clock and uh
this one it's as if it's reaching
boiling point finally we've been just
watching this position bubble bubble
bubble
and uh now boiling point he has to move
duda he's spending more time again he
has to move his knight maybe improve the
black queen the white
queen is attacking black central pawn
just defend it if you want to you just
have to move you have to decide like he
does defend it with his rook
now however the rook's not teaming up
not aligned with each other if you look
at the black brooks previously that was
where all the action was happening on
that e-file the black knights and white
bishops all stood on that file that's
why the evaluation passed slightly in
white's favor i think he should have
defended this pawn with the black queen
instead
and uh okay magnus does have a bit of a
luxury move here black has no threats
white's dart squad bishop can step into
the center of the board white's queen
can move
yeah
and also once the dark squared bishop
steps into the middle of the board just
look at the diagonal it's occupying and
look at the squares it's controlling
those squares around the black king and
then suddenly there are even
okay he does it with the queen
surprising to me because i was you can
guess what i was itching to do once i
centralized that bishop push some pawns
and push them as far up the board as
possible and open those lines but okay
magnus uh instead deciding to
well just improve the queen and finally
the rooks are connected and wow it seems
like doodler is the one reading my mind
but i don't know about this one
i think it's a little bit too
bold
pawns don't move backwards remember so
black's pawn pushes leave so many
weaknesses behind
look at the black king suddenly it's on
some open
diagonals and what does white have why
it has those bishops on the diagonals
so okay first magnus brings his rooks
closer to the center that's where the
action is kind of focused right now and
if the white bishops especially if
white's light squared bishop suddenly
lines up with the black king that's just
game over
so okay one of the black knights
stepping back away from its nice central
post attacking the white queen white's
queen will just slide one square back
most likely and uh yeah even if the
white queen continues getting harassed
by blacks knights remember white
for magnus a draw is fine it's an okay
result okay magnus doesn't just retreat
the queen allowing maybe a repetition
magnus
gesturing there shaking his head has he
just blended the pawn oh no he has
planted a pawn couldn't there be a trade
of queens and then suddenly oh look
there's a loose bishop on e2 but dude i
played it instantly
okay maybe this is
miss chance yeah i i'm struggling to
understand i'm trying to do some quick
calculation but it looks like both sides
just for that one moment missed
something
and uh
i would love to jump in because
yeah duda may be missing a huge
opportunity in this position magnus
offered a trade of queens but why can't
you just trade the queens off and then
now notice loose pieces drop off that's
one phrase that all chess players know
this is a loose piece white's light
squared bishop it's gonna drop off after
black's knight jumps out the way for
example taking a pawn in the process
after white recaptures whoops this
bishop drops and what has black done
black has won a pawn also this rook is
super strong
duda we saw the evaluation bar shoot up
in black's favor just for one move this
is very elementary this is really basic
he could have won a pawn maybe he didn't
want to head for the end game maybe he
thought magnus could hold the draw here
but
wow instead dude not going for the queen
trade he brought his queen to the center
he wants to go on the attack but
throwing his bishops around using this
bishop to go and capture a pawn
on the edge of the board seemingly a
useless pawn but that's because the
bishop if it's captured suddenly the
black knight next to it would lose its
protection and while things are really
heating up i mentioned they would the
black rook now stepping forward hitting
the white queen indirectly maybe the
bishop behind it on the sixth rank this
one is really chaotic suddenly there's a
huge threat if black's knight jumps out
the way then suddenly white will lose a
piece and magnus is grabbing pawns can
you grab that pawn i mean isn't there
some kind of attack like the knight can
step backwards
and uh look at that double attack one on
the bishop one on the rook yeah this is
really uh either this is really
mysterious and it's on the board i think
magnus's intention is to give up this
bishop he's about to lose it because of
this double attack i think he's going to
take this pawn and just accept the fact
that okay he's lost his bishop but he's
got three pawns in return
this one is chaotic now and this has
actually happened this position is on
the board also look at the white queen
she's on a nice diagonal against the two
rooks and against the black king this
one is crazy it's anyone's game
that's why look at the two players their
body language let's go back to them
because white has lost a bishop but he's
gained three pawns in the process is it
is he playing newborn kind of chess now
kind of kind of but with less risk
because uh he does have three pawns for
the piece um
lots and lots of moves coming thick and
fast but now the black queen is attacked
and maybe things are turning in magnus's
favor because if you step to the wrong
square with your queen for example uh if
you step away then white is going to be
delivering nasty checkmate to your king
at some point so okay the queen steps
back in this direction covering this key
square not allowing white to use it
this one's heating up but suddenly i'm
liking the pawns these pawns are going
to stop start running up the board they
are unrivalled three versus zero on this
side of the board and black's knights
are good but maybe not quite good enough
here they have no point and uh there's
also no way that the
the peace the extra black piece that
duda has can actually mobilize itself i
mean it's just in a purely defensive
role i think magnus has made a smart
choice and uh he's driving the knight
back
but uh i know i like your move better
david to the point promote the pawns
slightly scared of the white king now
the white king looking much more open
previously here it had nice shelter in
front of it that's why i thought okay
black has no threat why not push pawns
but
okay this pawn push now the black knight
is going to step i mean i'm not sure
where it could step back it can step
forward it at least threatens some
checks now uh the position okay and this
is happening magnus is he losing control
again no he drops his bishop back
there's a knight check and he's got to
be really careful but uh this black
queen now
can she jump into the position if she
jumps in there
drops off yeah she has to keep an eye on
her black rook so maybe sliding across
this way lining up with the white king
is still crazy let's go back to the
players 17 seconds plays one and a half
minutes
he has to make that move i think that is
the only move to keep the chances alive
and he retreats the queen
okay i mean
is there even moves such as
okay rick i was thinking of
what were you thinking about
i was thinking of decoying the queen but
okay maybe that wasn't possible nine
seconds for do that
and tension because look at the e file
now where white's rook lies black's
queen and rook as well three seconds
okay he pushes the pawn that was pure
panic and now look at this magnus just
locking in this black knight black's
knight in white's camp is trapped
that night now struggling to find an
escape square but there's a counter
attack against white's queen magnus
maybe just slightly rushing that last
move i think he could have won
once some material maybe but white's
queen now under fire where is she gonna
run to there's still this remaining
threat against black's knight on the e2
square it's trapped as mentioned
but how can magnus just close that cage
where is the safe square for white's
queen magnus this time frowning both
players super nervous you can tell on
the body language they really really
want to win this game both of them yeah
and white's queen i'm expecting her to
maybe just slide back she ideally wants
to keep herself on the same diagonal as
black's king but
then she will no longer attack black's
knight at the bottom of the board what's
the number one priority here it's not
clear
can she slide back one square on the
diagonal the problem is what okay she
does this i think the most natural move
the problem is now black's knight can
jump out the way white's queen not
attacking the black rook anymore and
okay magnus is pinning is he winning we
see a trade of pawns there the white
queen pinning the black rook but the
black rook defended sufficiently bar
saying it's a draw do you think it's
going to end up with a win for anybody
could still
both sides are running out pieces though
that's the problem we magnus though
banking on his pawns we could see a
scenario where the queens and rooks will
disappear black's knight will face off
against those three white pawns and
that could be very good for white that
could be very good for magnus if you can
push those pawns further but if the
pawn's full black has an extra night but
uh actually the position could be headed
into a draw because i suspect that
magnus will just step forward with his
queen pin the rogue and every time the
king tries to break the pin the queen
will just give a check well dude yeah i
was going to say will duda play for the
window uh magnus
gesturing there maybe he just missed
that this was possible because black's
knight is jumping towards that white
king
some vague threats now against white's
king from the black knight but magnus
ignores it nothing immediate to worry
about there is still this pin remember
black's rook is stuck cannot move
that would be illegal so black's queen
has to stay defending it as well
and also now that this knight has gone
to the right side is it in time to catch
the alice the a pawn
that's a good question white's pawn is
running very fast up the board so if
white now gets another move okay the
black knight defends its rooks i was
gonna say if white gets another move and
trades off the queens trades off the
rooks then that white pawn is simply
going to win the game but now the black
queen can move
and uh she does that and there's a big
threat on the board oh it's gonna be
it's gonna be checked he's shaking his
head black's queen wants to go on the
diagonal in front of the white king
that's checkmate in one move
dude has turned it around magnus is on
the brink of defeat suddenly the queen
coming to the f2 square in front of the
white king that's checkmate how do you
stop that threat you only you can only
do that maybe by trading queens but
black has an extra night at the end of
that
darkness he's blown it white's porn as
well the a pawn about to fall white's
pawn there it ran too far up the board
alice is lost and was it maybe the game
magnus oh my despondent it turned around
in one move
look at that reaction and young
christoph duda could be about to make a
comeback in this second match in the
final if he wins this one they're gonna
be tied in the second match
and if he wins another one well they
could be heading two tie breaks wow
magnus simply forgot that this was
checkmate in one threatened he thought
here that he could play rook takes rook
if white captures the black rook with
his rook black looks like he's forced to
recapture with the knight and white can
trade queens white actually wins there
maybe magnus thought he was winning he
simply forgot that if white captures the
black rook black doesn't need to
recapture the black queen swoops down
checkmate look at that black pawn on the
g3 square it supports a mating net as we
call it and uh okay magnus is forced to
trade queens but now the black rook is
going to slide across stop that white
pawn and
it's just a clean-up job as we said in
the last game the pawns are falling
there goes one it's now only two pawns
for white against that black knight it's
not enough black's knight is actually
going to become a very strong piece
shortly
and uh white needs to activate the king
it's an endgame after all but uh black
can even consider trading rooks here
possibly that can bring the rook across
with a check
swap those rooks off and maybe that's
winning for black it's still a bit of
calculation to be done dude can also
improve the black knight if he's unsure
yeah is winning it's his to lose i mean
just take a look at uh duda i mean what
a change
he's suddenly
leaning forward looking at his pieces he
is in full calculation mode he knows his
luck has turned and uh yeah this is now
incredible for
black
and it's not even too difficult i feel
no the black knight once it improves
itself there we go going to the edge of
the board but it's going to
re-centralize itself soon
it's all about black's g3 porn that we
did mention that's two squares away from
promotion if black can remove the port
in front of it especially with the black
knight it's just gonna be game over
magnus's pawns they're actually held up
right now they're stuck because the
black rook keeps an eye on them and uh
magnus
can he pull another miracle out of the
bag he goes active with the kick i think
this is a good practical chance um if
duda does decide to give a check this is
okay but uh the white king can just
slide on the diagonal and uh okay are we
going to see it
yeah the problem is i think you can
safely take this pawn in the next move
no matter where white goes oh yeah
because there's going to be a chat
there's always going to be a check
knights are so tricky that white pawn
now is going to drop black's knight can
simply feast on it on the g2 square
attacking the white rook
okay instead dude offers a trade of
rooks yeah if the rooks disappear
black's knight is simply going to gobble
up that pawn and win the game ah yeah
and also black's king noticed if the
rooks get traded off black's king is
easily in time to stop white's pawns
whereas white's king now too far away to
stop black spawns
so dude are really sensitive to the
moment and he understands where the
kings belong
so magnus will not uh yeah yeah he does
not want to trade afterwards he has to
run away he has to keep his pawn guarded
look how sad this rook feels right now
guarding just a mere pawn in front of it
now the black rook can even come down
and attack that pawn reinforce
the threat there that looks very strong
black's king could also start just
meandering across towards the white
pawns just to stop them ever advancing
too much choice black could also give a
check with this rook
actually maybe
that's just very strong giving a check
with the black rook now white's king no
matter where it goes the black knight
can jump in black can even be a bit
flashy and uh think about giving up his
rook got to be a bit careful but jumping
in with the knight and we're seeing
exactly that
and uh now just go and capture a pawn
looks very safe and all the pawns
dropping white can't even get
enthusiastic and try to say hey i'm
going to pin your knight because the
knight can just take a step backwards
and magnus
trying this trick but the knight steps
back rook is protected and suddenly
yeah it's uh the knight is easily going
to hold off white's outside passport
meanwhile it is going to be the pawn on
g3 is going to win the game for duda and
it's going to be a big comeback wow just
when it seemed like magnus
had banked it actually you know he was
playing a great game and then it got
wild
and uh magnus was the one that blundered
last was he um too confident at some
point they're magnus i think so and for
the first time really in this whole
match yesterday and today magnus was
quite long time in a wild position it's
that key word wild wild favors duda
if it's a controlled position just
maneuvering slow steady that favors
magnus so okay here we go dude is king
just making it move over to this left
side to stop white's pawn and as ivanka
mentions black's knight eventually is
going to go back the other way
towards the right side of the board and
pick off the remaining white pawns there
once duda has dealt with this left side
of the board that one remaining hope and
uh okay well he doesn't even do that uh
he just steps forward with the black
king
and uh oh wow actually magnus doesn't
even try to save this game he resigns in
a hopeless end game yep